it's like i got to ask what was like the
anime community like when were you you
were in like your full
weeb phase because you you like i love
racism
you like fully embraced it right like
how was anime conventions and everything
for you
yeah i wish i never went to anime
convention until like 2017. yeah my
first anime convention was like 20
20 like 2012 or something like that it's
still early yeah
yeah i hadn't even started youtube at
that point yeah wait so where was the
what year was the first anime convention
2009.99
yeah um it was anime milwaukee anime
milwaukee hit me up bro
no it's anime milwaukee and um i
remember because obviously i said i was
a full weep and everyone says like glob
i'm like oh my god that's so original
oh my
i just lost the game and i'm like that's
the most clever [ __ ] [ __ ]
wait what is gomping uh glomping is when
you
do you want to explain that you don't
know what glory is is that the
thing where you jump on yeah they're
just like
it's like it's like you come up to a
random person and you literally just
like hug
yeah yeah and sometimes it's it's it's
like the most aggressive hug
you can it hurts it's like a rugby
tackle that's what it's like it's such
really always yeah
why is like so many things in anime
conventions just sound right like i
didn't
i didn't know you i didn't i didn't know
you could be assaulted by a hug until i
experienced the glomp
i'm just like oh that felt dirty what
the hell what the hell was that
do you what do you think of free hugs
like i can't [ __ ] stand the free hugs
thing
i'm like why would i want to hug a
sweaty stranger that is the last thing i
ever want to do i i actually like
before the whole roano thing happened
like i remember going to shibuya and
almost every time there's like a thing
there's a free hug sign i'm like what
who does this it's 2019
who does this if it's like a viewer
who's like i want a hug i'm like
i got you but if it's like just someone
standing there who's been hugged by like
a hundred different people that damn i
don't want your hugs
yeah your herpes ridden hugs get it off
of me
but like yeah cause it's like you don't
know what they want from you like do you
want to feel my like
tender breasts on your sweaty showerless
body
yeah exactly it's like it just looks
really rapey to me like
i'm i'm in like the one meter radius and
i can smell the like like axe
i can feel it in my pores yeah i don't
know i just even when i was younger i
just thought the [ __ ] was stupid like
yeah i don't know if like
yeah maybe someone british i don't know
we just yeah i think i don't know like
stupid yeah i mean i just like my
personal space and i remember like
like go go go into anime conventions
back in the day just seemed like
everyone looked for an excuse just to
violate your personal space as much as
possible
oh yeah and uh man remember like yowie
paddles and that entire [ __ ] face
when that was yeah welcome you're lucky
then okay i i've i've watched a number
of videos on the
redbard's videos
i was like i'm so glad i wasn't a
convictions during that time
yeah it just it just seemed like what i
heard about my week people just
hit you and no one had a problem with
that yeah that's just a physical assault
yeah extra steps yeah
physical assault with attitude
it's like if i just put the word like
like hentai on a belt and we're like
it's the hentai belt
son it's time
when i heard about the yowie paddle
right i heard stories about it's like
this is gonna this is gonna look amazing
yeah this thing
they've everyone's hitting it it must be
amazing if everyone's just letting it
fly yeah i see it and it's just like
burned in yowie like sans serif
font into a panel and i'm like this is
what everyone let each other hit them
there was like i've seen pictures of
like old conventions where they were
selling it
at like yeah they sold them yeah and i'm
like what is this [ __ ] hunger games
like it's just like
readily available go to war everybody
it just proves that they will literally
buy anything at an anime convention if
you just put the words yowie on it yeah
like
it's a [ __ ] wooden panel there is
literally nothing
special about this why are people buying
this material cost is like 10 cents
you're selling it for like five bucks
it's there's so much [ __ ] now to make a
bedroom like who's buying this
like i you know oh my god i mean i know
i feel i feel like it's just
it's just evolved because now i think
i'm british now if you want to sell
something okay now i'm going to sell
something in an anime convention just
put a [ __ ]
face on it that [ __ ] will sell like hot
cakes you know
i remember i would see people go around
with like these these steins
like the metal like steins i'm like why
is everyone holding a stein
and the [ __ ] is a stein like a really
big like
like german uh like mug and it was like
oh
and there was just someone like the at
like the vendors it was just selling
like
like weird kind of concoctions and i was
this is why why are you carrying around
a metal ass jug all day that you can
refill when you just drink some [ __ ]
water out of
like you ever have a water bottle to
hold a [ __ ] glass all day
yeah this thing was huge yeah and i'm
just like what is wrong with anime fans
don't buy anything that's put in front
of them like yeah it's a deal though
maybe maybe if you looked closely at the
stones
my parents just [ __ ] they just told
me everything that you don't need is a
scam connor
like seven up you don't need that you
got water it's a scam
[Music]
what's the difference mcdonald's sprite
oh my god have you ever had mcdonald's
mcdonald's but it's just
actually why would i walk into a
mcdonald's when i used to
that that that is true that is why when
i used to work at mcdonald's because
it's like a syrup right it's like a
yeah so when we had to like connect it
one time i got like the
the coke syrup on my hands and i was
like
[Laughter]
and it was like like the sweetest it was
i imagine that's what
15 year old me thought doing a line of
coke was like this [ __ ] was so
sweet and juicy oh my god it was amazing
succulent
succulent it was amazing that was
beautiful and that was the only good
thing that ever happened working did you
guys
did you guys ever see the yowie guy at
like the first some of the first
conventions
there was this guy right i don't know
how he got all around the world but he'd
go around some of the biggest
conventions
and you'd know it was the yowie guy
because there was there would be this
one booth
that would be something like yaoi and
the jinchi's and there there would just
be this guy that would just just keep
shouting out
yeah we get your yowie yes
yes i've met him you've met him i've met
him he was at a convention in finland
yeah i'm like i think i saw you in
america
like last month why are you here i saw
him at like an asan convention and then
i saw him again at like
mcm two months later i don't know how he
just like
and he he he would always shout this out
and i remember
telling me
i remember because of how aggressively
he would [ __ ] sell yowie to girls
like girls would come up and he goes
yoko what you want what yaoi do you want
you
this girl is buying gay porn everyone
she is buying yowie hi what yowie do you
want and then you
and then the guys would come up and
there would be a different guy selling
dojinshi's at the same booth yeah and it
would be like this indiscreet
drug dealer being like yo yo yo boy
what'd you want like no one has to see
oh i'll [ __ ] bag it up no one has to
see it'll be coming to paperback
penetration
yeah i don't know like i think he's got
gotten banned or something now because i
haven't seen him
that would annoy the [ __ ] out of me yeah
because like thinking back i'm like man
that probably wasn't cool for like any
girl who just wanted to indiscreetly buy
something
something oh it is like the next level
sexual assault
right it's like it's like it's like the
most like big brain sexual assault it's
like i'm not actually assaulting you
sexually but i kind of am by words yeah
i love anime conventions but i just feel
like i'm like out of my league man i'm
like i get there and i'm like i love
the atmosphere but sometimes you just
see weird [ __ ] and you're like all right
okay
i'm gonna head out i i don't know what
it is when i hear about uh you go to ax
or something and hear about a group of
guys who have met on discord and
like and like rent out airbnb together
for some reason
90 of the time that just never ends
[Music]
i hear that i'm just like that's that's
that's how murders happen
the thing i thought was like right
listen this hotel's expensive yeah i
don't care
who is gonna be in this room yeah i need
to just fill it and get this price down
that's it first yeah i'm i'm broke as
[ __ ] i need this hotel to cost
100 for this whole thing or i'm out yeah
yeah
you kind of like take the area of like
the hotel room and you're like
how many times can i divide this by a
human body so okay that's how many
bodies are sleeping in this room right
you've got to become the host
if you want the host no one can argue
whether you get like the right
yeah it's like well i arranged it what
are you gonna do it's in my name yeah
what do you mean maybe take the floor
you wouldn't dare